Hello everyone.
Ah yes, that's better.
I want to say that I'm alive right now, but I don't know.
I'm unsure at the moment.
It's a little bit...
A little bit hard to tell.
Are you on life support?
I might as well be.
Oh, okay.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I need to fix this jet lag.
Okay, it's the comment.
i'm sorry i know like this week i've been pushing the stream
like up a lot but like i didn't the jet lag plus plus the
blood is not helping thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you big coffee funds thank you guys i really
appreciate the patience after today's stream i do have
tomorrow as a rest day i'm gonna try and try and reset reset
myself oh my god oh the period that's what i'm trying you
know how i for those who did not watch yesterday's stream um
i i haven't had my period in seven months
so and i got it hit me yesterday it finally happened
yesterday and and and so my body it's my body is trying to
remember what it's like to be a woman and and it's not
working out so well
so and I'm jet lagged too and and I'm jet lagged so my body
is like so so I'm alive question why oh director thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you please i'm supposed
to be the tad one here yeah my potty is falling apart right
now nsd thank you super chat thank you thank you wait does
the most armor core pilots are mentally unwell so this is
more accurate also i i had uh i had i i so what happened was
i couldn't sleep so i played a little bit of street fighter
after the collab and then it was like seven in the morning
i'm so frustrated right now with street fighter because i
i've hit a it's always like i've hit a stopping point in my
rank up because every time i would play boot up the game i
would rank up a little bit um every time like little by
little so i have like the strats marinating in my head.
But I try to play Street Fighter.
I try to play Street Fighter this morning.
Like, I don't know, I guess this morning.
And, like, I've hit a wall because, like, I couldn't rank
up.
So, and I kept, like, going up and down, up and down, up and
down.
Like, I lose, win, lose, win, lose, win.
And I was, like, so frustrated.
I was like, why?
Why am I not learning?
It's like, I need, I need to at least hit plat.
I need to, like, everyone's going to be diamond.
So, at least, I need to be at least plat.
Like, I have to be at least plat against these diamond
players.
That's my goal.
So, I won't look too sad.
I don't want to look too sad during the tournament.
Yeah.
and yeah and then um to be fair i haven't had a coaching
session in like two plus days so that's why i think i also i
hit a wall because i would always get like a coaching
session and then i and then my in between my gaming sessions
so then every time i would reach that wall for coaching
session because the coaching stuff would marinate in my head
and i and then i implement in the next session but I haven't
done it yet because my sleep schedule is so fucked up right
now my sleep schedule is not okay for me think of the super
chat thank you thank you miss bird get up bright and glam
super dokey wake up beam thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you yeah I've been exchanging my coaching sessions
for sleeping sessions which is not great I mean it's great
for me I get to sleep but anyway long story short today I
had a panel and a panel and a meet and greet today so
obviously I should sleep but my panel is in the East Coast
so because it's in the east coast um it was earlier than i
earlier than i thought it'd be
so 7 a.m street fighter and then 9 a.m panel so that i slept
for an hour and you're like wait dokie but you stopped at 7
a.m yes i stopped playing street fighter at 7 a.m doesn't
mean I went to bed at 7 a.m.
so so I had an hour nap between and then right after that I
had I had a 12 p.m.
um I had a 12 p.m.
meeting greet and so I slept another hour uh another hour
for the meeting greet but Doki the panel was only an hour
yes the panel might ended at 10 a.m.
but it doesn't mean i slept at 10 a.m so um so and then
right after the mean and greet i took another uh i took
another nap because if i got i'm working off of naps right
now i'm so when i woke up at four uh four four fifty I saw a
got a message from my manager and he was like hey are you
still awake and I was like I think so he's like oh can you
respond to this right now and I was just like can you push
my waiting room 30 minutes
so I I was like I literally I was like I could get up right
now like at 450 i was like i could get up right now but i
could i could do another nap gotcha and i did i it won i was
just like i i had to nap that extra no you don't understand
that extra 30 minutes no you don't understand at 450 i was
not a real person at at 5 20 at 5 20 i was still not a real
person but at least i could get out of bed there's a
difference there's a difference between like um legal
definition of being alive and also alive still that that
extra 30 minutes hits um let's see uh Kyle, thank you for
the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hopefully, Doki will be full awake if the Knicks win
tonight.
Oh, I didn't they win already?
Or is there still more games?
I'm sorry, I'm not a basketball player.
But, like, I thought there was a riot in New York City
because, like, they won something.
Did they not win yet?
Or was that, like, the semis?
They need one more.
Oh, I see.
uh genesis they give a super chat thank you thank you may
this bird get a bright oh i read it that's thank you thank
you again airborne ninja they give a super chat thank you
thank you how far can this bird fly on borrowed wings thank
you the super chat thank you thank you thunder sleeper they
give this super chat yeah i don't wait win or loss new york
city is gonna get burned down there's technically no winning
except for the people who are there as a tourist again All
right, Doki, it's my, what's my birthday name?
It's better late than never to ask this.
Can you sing me a happy, of course I can, bro.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear thunder.
Yeah, happy birthday.
Yippee Wait, I could maybe get an extra coaching session
live right now We'll still play Let me be that Yeah, oh
yeah, oh yeah He was Oh yeah, my coach is playing 2xKO stage
I'm stunned So he's like dividing time between 2xKO and
Capcom and Street Fighter Yeah, I think you were in 2xKO
Because I feel like the moment I finish playing Armor Core I
will be pronounced uh lily dead for two for like four hours
i think four to five hours and and so and then he'll be
offline i and so maybe i can sneak something in before i
yeah before it before it i know i should just stay up but i
don't think i i i know i should stay up right after stream
but i don't think my body knows i don't I feel like, I don't
know.
I don't know what my body knows.
Yeah.
True, I might get a second win.
Are you free today for some coaching?
I've hit a wall with my...
Okay, I'm hard stuck in goal three.
Okay, when I woke up, woo, I woke up in time, time, this is
gonna be good, thank you, super chat, somber, thank you,
thank you, I could get coffee, but coffee, while you're on
your time of the year is actually not a very good
combination, I know it's crazy, but apparently, okay, a
little fun fact for you guys, do not give coffee to women
when it's their time of the year, because, um, because it
actually, actually, uh, what's the word?
It actually, um, enhances the flow.
It makes it worse.
So with coffee, it's like, you know, maybe it's like a
waterfall.
And then when you add coffee in there, it's like you breach
the dam.
It amplifies.
I don't know how it does it.
It's like, like yeah it's very bad so I technically I should
not drink coffee if I was a if I was a smart person I
shouldn't drink coffee oh yeah some little fun facts for you
guys also yeah I guess it intensifies cramps too I guess yes
a little fun for everybody um sometimes i i sometimes i
ignore that fun fact all right it's time for our record all
right let's see my oh she is not a smart person exactly i'm
debating right now as long as i keep drinking water i'm
replenishing my My blood.
As long as I still continue to drink water while this is
going on.
At least I won't die from lack of blood.
Alright.
Alright, we're at court.
Guys, I actually don't remember how to play this game.
I just know that.
I just know I have many multiple big booms.
Oh Lying in I really appreciate Guys everyone's patience
With my really Fucked up sleep Schedule It's not great I
really appreciate Everyone's patience today It's true Oh Oh,
my beautiful GoonBot.
Hell, I miss you.
As always, we're...
GoonBot is looking for sponsors.
We're looking...
We are open for one sponsor on GoonBot.
We got...
Guys, guys, we gotta be able to keep up the maintenance.
We need, we are open for one sponsor of the day.
Would anyone like to have this free, well not free real, pay
the real estate?
There's so much space here.
You can put it on anywhere you like.
Well, how do I do this again?
I don't even remember.
how much depends on how much ad space you want
come on guys look at all that ad space guys we're looking
for a sponsor right now to keep up the upkeep place eyes for
doggy shirt only right on their face so you that face okay
solid snake i would love to take the sponsorship but like
look this is the head right let me let me show you where
that this is the head this i can fit like two of those words
and like eyes for doggy shirt only right on you so you can't
see shit i can put face on there Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
My ad for the goon bot.
What is sleep?
Yeah, two letters.
All right, I can do that.
All right.
What is sleep?
I can do that, though.
All right.
Oh, fuck.
I forgot to write.
Um.
wait is white okay okay what I need to change the color how
do how do change color change oh W color color change oh
edit color color change oh edit color all right i got
grandma's back how to download this new how to download this
video from from youtube grandson i found this funny youtube
about this fat woman on that bridge and then when she jumps
everybody fell down but then the dog saves everyone it's
such a such a heartwarming video my god when the dog saved
everyone from the bridge that the fat woman destroyed oh
crap but that's ai but it's so real but it looks so real
what do you mean ai son but look at this poor taco all right
what all right what
oh no do not know don't discard it what oh my there was like
at some point i'm it's getting a little harder to tell what
is ai And there are some videos where I will say it is sort
of, it's starting to get harder.
It really is starting to get harder to distinguish between
AI and real.
That's the scary part because it's always learning.
We truly live in a society.
Alright, and then we'll add another one.
to me what is what is what did you see the one did you guys
see that tweet about like an indian guy made 6 000 plus
dollars in one stream because he used a an ai the the ai
filters to make him look like an at like uh like a bishiman
like an anime boy like not like a 2d anime boy but like you
know like like a super lots of makeup uh lots of makeup and
oh my god Asian guy like oh my wait let me show you let me
show you guys the tweet I was like six thousand I'm in the
wrong field I'm sorry I'm joking I'm joking uh I do wonder
what it would look like Like if I put it on like a 2D anime
girl.
A 22 year old Indian who turned himself into an animicator.
Made $6,400 in six hours.
He spent $20 on Claude.
Claude changed his appearance and voice in real time.
Women liked the look so much that they started donating.
The biggest donation was $750.
In six hours, $6,400.
And Fot that's insane.
I was like, I won't never, I won't never touch it.
But I was like, what?
And I was like, how much of a transformation is that?
And then, oh my God.
Like, that's, I feel like I wouldn't know it was a, I don't
know.
I don't know if I would have known it was a I or not.
like I don't know like the one the quoted though I would
have not known this was AI like the quote retweet of the one
with the girl not the anime boy the one with the girl was
fucking crazy like that's insane like like like like people
were donating to him with the fact that he was like, he just
looked like this anime, I don't know, this fucking anime boy
again.
Yeah.
I was just like, oh my god, like excited for the dokeybird
bushman skin suit.
Get that back.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I was like, oh, Holy shit.
Let's see.
I'm not gonna fly.
I think you cleared that easily.
You got a Bishin Min model.
Thank you, the super chat, Rice.
Thank you, thank you.
You guys think so?
Do you think I could be a beautiful man?
Really?
I feel like I sound like a boy that just hit puberty.
I'm not.
I'll be like, hey, everybody.
You're sick.
Daddy is here.
Do you want Daddy?
I don't know, guys.
Do you think it'll work?
Do you think I can pull that off?
You want...
You got fuck boy potential.
No.
Guys, do you think I can pull it off, guys?
You cannot send it.
never mind all right um let me okay where is the e button
okay e oh my god guys you really think so you really think I
can pull it off wow we okay what What is...
What is...
Sleep.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
We got it.
Alright.
And then I'll put a decal.
No.
Paint.
Which one was it?
uh no how do i put things on how oh decal i guess like oh
custom decal all right where do we put that i guess we'll
put it we could put that you know what we'll put it on the
head and then we'll put it on the head what what is sleep
we'll put it here and then there
we go thank you for the sponsor you have funded goon goon
bots i shouldn't say you have funded goon bots life for
another day uh hat and clogs thank you for super chat thank
you thank you put on your dad's valentine's voice and send
you'll make millions off of certain dragoons alone.
Hey, everybody.
I feel like I'm a chain smoker.
Hey, guys.
Sexy Mad Doki Bird is here.
Ladies, ladies.
Daddy's here.
Ladies.
Ladies, ladies, come that one at a time.
That's so hot.
Please stop.
Okay.
Thank you for sponsoring Goombat.
Goombat.
We appreciate your patronage.
Who is the Sluncatcher survivor?
Okay.
I'm lowering you down.
Please, Suki, you're on YouTube.
That's right, girls.
The socks stay hot.
All right.
I'm down for coaching in an hour if you're still.
free all right let's go do i should i i should do arena
before i do it all right we're gonna we're gonna beat up
invincible rummy because i never brought play this game all
right
welcome to the arena combat aptitude program my big boom's
here yeah i'll be your ek man guys what's the between ekman
and bishuman they're both beautiful men right like what's
the difference between a dude guys thank you richard thank
you thank you identity theft is not a joke dokey how dare
you copy dad okay okay oh i remember now i remember you know
what no i would never forget how to Oh.
Oh.
Big boom.
Okay, I'm just gonna stand here.
You can...
You can try and dig me all you want.
But, like...
Technically, I'm stronger.
You can...
Look, I know technically I'm stronger here.
So you can...
No, it's just me trying to remember how to play this game.
There we go.
Oh, Ike is handsome.
Oh, Ike.
Okay, should I be an Ike man?
Or a Bishu man.
Okay, Ikeu man is beautiful.
And then Ike is handsome, right?
Oh, so like Ike is see me and...
And...
Bishu is...
What was it called?
Uke?
Okay, Ikiman is cool, handsome guy.
Bishiman is pretty, a beautiful guy.
Ikiman is incredibly handsome woman.
Wait, then what am I?
Alright.
I'm gone.
I'm so gone right now.
Oh, it's like, Watashiwa.
Yeah, I'm fucking speaking Japanese as if it's like the
first time I've ever heard it.
Watashiwa, Toki, Jesu.
God.
And I see, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
You say, hello, princess.
Yeah, there you go.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Alright guys, I think I'm ready.
I think I remember how to play the game.
Um, anyway.
Am I more of a beautiful, beautiful man or a handsome man?
Is that difference again?
I already forgot.
Am I EK man or a Bishu man?
I'm a Tameen.
I'm a handsome man.
Thank you guys.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Call that voice, the NBA.
No bitches attached.
All right, mission.
Oh, I didn't read that.
All right.
Okay, wait, hear me out.
What if you had a Ouija-themed skin where you're a beautiful
man?
All right, so you're a super chat.
Thank you.
I don't wonder.
I think I definitely don't understand one of the words in
that sentence.
Now I've got rival dozers muscling in.
It's the junker coyotes.
Whoa.
Damn, one of them looks fucking weird.
That's a weird-ass mecha design.
It's like a skeleton.
What's Wooshia?
What is Wooshia?
They might be a pack of dumb animals.
But at least they know quality workmanship.
I'm gonna Google Wooshia.
Oh!
I know what Wooshia is.
No, I know it.
I sort of was like...
Is it what I think?
it is and then no I know it's a particular type of genre of
comics that are based around it yeah yeah yeah it's it's a
I've seen the comics
I know it's not usually based off of those comics but a lot
of the the comics have those particular like it's based off
of this particular uh design yeah we're beautiful men battle
it out in their the sky martial arts i've i've seen it
before i know what you're talking about all right let's see
eliminate the junker coyotes a faction invading grade 086
and our wars based on number of m oh okay that's fine i got
this where they cross swords and touch tips you know the
sword ships of course oh thank you my robot ai waifu that's
gonna be our the future someday
that's that's gonna be our future someday
All right
My beautiful guys, how do I?
Where's my my eagle vision?
Again, I don't remember.
Okay, there's the control
Yeah, have you that's right you never seen a big boy
That's right!
Didn't see the big boom before!
Oh my gosh, give me a sec.
Big boom is coming in hot right now.
There we go.
Alright.
Guys, how do I do Armor core vision again, guys.
I don't remember.
It's camouflage!
I'm blending in with my surroundings, guys.
Does no one know the concept of camouflage anymore?
Oh, just scan.
There you go.
I was trying to figure out how to do that.
We do?
Oh shit, we do.
That's right, it's me!
Oh my god.
Where is it?
Oh shit, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
Oh shit!
I got confused.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Guys, how to heal?
How to heal?
How?
Guys, heal how?
Oh, no.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Where?
What?
That's about mouse and keyboard.
No!
Wait, I can say.
Have I actually eliminated them?
Oh, wait, I did it.
Up on Z-pad!
You say on my keyboard...
Oh, it's fine, I live.
Whatever.
I'm so good at this game.
It's H for healed, obviously.
Yay!
I'm so...
It's like I'm armored to the core.
I did it.
Guess you noticed that job from Balaam and decided to take
it.
I see you're heading for the cargo launcher now.
Not a bad idea.
I'll give you that.
Keep heading for the ice field.
I'll take care of some loose ends in the meantime.
What does C stand for?
The C for Kiel?
C for Camo.
We go back in.
I don't even know if I need to buy anything.
Anyone need to buy anything at this point.
Like I feel like I'm so jacked up.
Oh C for C.
Oh my god.
Ah yes.
The Kingdom Hearts Cure.
C for Cure.
That's so smart.
I got you.
Continental Cargo Launcher Found D-Win the outer shell of
Upper Grid 086
Alright We're continuing through Grid 086 Toward the
Intercontinental Cargo Launcher
As promised Carla has agreed to serve as our guide I I need
to trust a dozer But if we turn her down We turn her
knowledge to the She's a black widow.
But if the fires happened half a century ago.
Oh my gosh, she's 50 years old.
It could just be some dozer inside joke.
Wait, no, that's me.
She was a...
I mean, she could have controlled the Mecca as a baby.
Guys, if my math is correct, she could be 50 years old.
Guys, guys, if my math is correct, guys, you think my math's
correct?
All right, reach the Continental Cargo Launcher found deep
within the outer shell of Upper Grid 086.
This will be our third sortie together.
It's close enough.
I think I think I think that's I think it's correct
all right here you go oh my gosh she's so old that she's
like in her mid 50s main system activating combat mode she
could be a prodigy her mom could have given birth to her in
the mecca and then her mom died and then the baby piloted
the mecca You know, it could work.
I mean, there are child labor laws for it, but like, it
still could work.
Alright, access.
This elevator goes straight to the top of the grid.
The outer shell.
Sadly, that's beyond my territory.
I mean, once you're out there, the PCA satellites see
everything.
Alright, nice.
Oh,
guess what?
What happened?
Are we there yet?
Are we... Oh, we're there.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh.
I'm oh don't worry my tank can go fast okay let me all right
don't worry let me let me position myself real quick guys
let me uh let me get that oh all right all right watch this
let me rev the engine get warmed up
as fast as I know it's so bad oh shit guys this might not be
as fast as it oh my god oh my god
guys I was just too fast you know wait I can do this I guys
guys I was just so it was just luck you know uh it was guys
it was just luck that they hit me guys oh pure luck they
just shot randomly and coincidentally they hit the shot wait
is that like a little hole that you go into a little oh my
god you mean i could have been under here this entire time
this little hole i found myself a little how do i get out of
this little hole um
yeah am i like more in my how do i leave this tiny hole
though
Alright.
Boom!
Big boom!
Oh shit, what am I shooting at?
Alright, there we go.
That should be five.
all right that oh wait i'm shooting my demons obviously all
right okay this is there another another underground part
for me to go to oh no okay wait give me a sec uh you think i
I could be fast enough.
All right.
Don't worry.
It's possible.
Oh my god, it's too long.
Like, they're like, please make a decision.
All right, watch this.
Oh, shit.
Nobody's gonna catch me.
Brute forces.
It is then.
Guys, do you think they know I'm here?
All right, we're okay.
You're damn fine.
It's okay.
Oh.
I think I'm fine.
I think I got a win.
Nice moves.
Thank you.
I thought I was pretty nice.
Okay.
Oh my god.
What hit me?
Boom.
Please, big boom.
Boom!
That's what I like to see.
Let's get the cargo launcher ready.
Alright, I need a resupply.
See it?
Look at that.
I told you.
Guys, I told you H build will always will always prevail.
No one can kill me.
Now, if you could just step inside.
Wait.
Enemy detected.
Whoa, shit!
Ooh, shit.
Oh, there she is.
There's Kyla.
Jesus Christ.
Is that her?
Wait, where did she go?
Oh, fuck!
That's right, bye!
That's five.
I am unstoppable.
Jesus Christ.
I am still...
I am not doing any damage.
I don't understand.
But I'm big boom.
How am I not doing any damage?
I don't understand.
Oh god, I don't have any more There's no way You guys Guys,
guys, this is not looking so good.
This is not
Holy shit.
She's more tanky than me She's more than just big boom
that's hearsay big boom is all I need
that's hearsay
Jesus Christ I how do I dodge that
Okay.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, my God.
I can't see anything.
No way.
Okay.
Oh, God.
suddenly.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
Oh, my god.
It can be complete!
It can take damage!
That's crazy!
Oh, shit.
It's taking me damage.
Oh, no, shit.
Really?
Oh god.
That's my last repair kit.
Holy shit.
Oh, fuck.
Oh my god.
That's not fair.
What?
Now it can fly.
What the fuck?
What can I do?
That's not fair!
Oh my god.
They can fly!
Oh my god, they fly now.
They fly now.
Big boom will not give up.
I know what to do because Guys, I know what to do.
Okay.
I don't know, but it's flying.
Oh, shit.
It tried to squash me.
Oh my god.
Big boom!
Wow!
Big boom, big boom to me!
Jesus Christ, I'm reloading!
Okay.
All
right.
Jesus Christ.
Big boom in eye.
We're booming it out.
Oh my god, please.
I'm trying.
I'm trying, but they're...
Okay.
Jesus.
Christ only fuck
Jesus it just squishes me guys I don't know guys no big boom
never doubt big boom we never doubt this build no I never
doubt it.
It's okay.
We gotta believe!
Alright.
If you could just step inside.
We gotta believe!
Okay.
If only I can have a bigger boom.
That's so true.
Honestly, the one thing I'm lacking is just a bigger boom.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, God.
Okay, this might not be the run.
This might...
I have a feeling this might not be the run, guys.
Oh, my God.
What if I'm...
just on top of it oh guys being do not be on top of it do
not be on top of it it might not have been the smartest
thing i've done what was behind me okay
guys just i might i guys i know guys i know it's here say,
but I don't think Big Boom's track is worth it.
I, it might be, yes, yes, because I don't think, I don't
think Big Boom, no,
yeah, not with that attitude, no, oh, it's Big Boom, all
right, wait, okay, what if it's Big Boom, But we change our
legs Maybe Guys, guys Alright, alright, alright Alright, big
boom But we Our legs Our legs are different Maybe that's it
That We can still be Big boom We just have Okay, we'll just
have legs We'll just have legs Wait, cannot do to excess
load Oh god, I cannot hold up too many booms I wait does it
like remove all of the no it should be fine okay i need to
buy stronger legs no i can't buy stronger legs i skipped leg
day oh no oh no
all right okay we gotta get rid of one big boom
unfortunately i know i know i'm so sorry guys we have to we
have to get rid of one okay would this help what the fuck is
this gun what do we need okay uh time for bigger boom okay i
don't know what Gun this is, but, oh, I cannot.
Never mind.
Oh, my gosh.
I already forgot what my build was.
Not gonna lie.
I think that was the original build.
Swap the arms and body.
To what, though?
Oh.
What can I even swap?
Me, that?
how many load do i need okay
i can't even tell what is okay wait wait no my arms are are
really light i just noticed but wouldn't that be more weight
is that not is that more weight or that yeah that's more
weight
oh okay
i guess these are light oh there we go all right i'm ready
all right here we go what the fuck
oh yeah wait how to activate the flag in okay there we go
and then all right here we go big boom time for real i can't
i'm just Dads are so weird.
So it's like really weird to read.
All right.
What is it?
Oh, fuck, okay.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, he stopped me!
Oh, my God!
He just stopped me!
There was no, my, guys.
I somehow did worse.
Maybe, okay, what if it's the...
Maybe just regular legs.
Maybe, yeah, maybe.
legs would be better okay I can't do that my god I'm still
so heavy I we need to get rid of like oh oh wait this would
be better I'm almost there I just need just a little bit
more just a little tie in your head All right.
No, no.
Weapon will never...
No, guys.
No.
I'll...
Guys, I'll get rid of one weapon.
Okay.
I have to hit that one tiny area.
Uh...
But then my gun is all...
They're all so big.
Okay.
Maybe this...
Oh my god.
We're almost there.
I gotta learn a new weapon, but we're almost there, guys.
Okay, there we go.
I don't know what the fuck my build is right now.
I don't...
Alright, look for a better...
Alright.
Okay.
That's fine.
Now, if you could just step inside.
Wait.
Enemy detected.
Oh shit, that was an accident actually.
What?
Guys.
I don't know, man.
I...
That machine was created by a bunch of mad scientists.
There you go.
oh my god get in there oh my god how did it up i don't know
how i managed to that up guys oh my god please stop guys i
Okay.
There we go.
We're figuring out the strat, guys.
We're figuring it out.
I just gotta be, like, right above him.
And then...
Just do that.
Boom, big boom, and then slash, slash, and then a big boom
again.
My mini booms.
Oh, fuck.
Guys, I think it's working.
Oh, God.
Okay, there we go.
Slash!
Boom!
Oh god.
Oh god!
He pooped!
No!
It was working!
Wait, I figured it out.
Guys!
I figured it out!
This was better.
I figured it out.
They don't know how to look.
Oh shit.
Okay.
They don't know how to look up.
It was working!
I don't remember how to use my pulse armor, guys.
Guys, how do I use my pulse armor?
Oh shit, that did not mean to do that.
Alright.
Guys, I'm- oh fuck!
She was created by a bunch of mad scientists to rest.
The fires of Ibis may have taken the institute.
Here you go.
All right.
I'm on M&K, guys.
For those who don't remember.
All right.
Those who are trying to talk to me and controller speak, it
might not be helpful.
Just a baby.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Guys, oh, my god.
Yes, I know.
I know my AI was.
Okay.
It sure is.
Oh, shit.
But I might be also taking damage.
Woo.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Oh, shit.
That's not what I meant.
Skysore.
Oh, fuck.
Everything is going wrong.
Right now.
I'm on top of it.
I'm on top of it right now.
I'm...
Oh, shit.
Oh, it's going to start flying now, it's gonna start flying!
No.
No!
Oh, it's...
How do I do it?
Is it...
See?
Control R?
Oh, it's because I looked over the screen the moment I...
the moment I saw it.
It's okay, guys, guys, I'm learning.
I'm machine learning right now.
Guys, I'm like AI.
Now, if you could just step inside.
Watch this, guys.
Wham!
Boom!
Big boom!
Big boom me.
That was my bet.
Okay, I may have got a little bit overconfident.
There.
Jesus Christ, I'm...
Fuck!
Woo!
There you go.
All right.
Boom!
Oh my god, it is.
But I am also taking damage too, robot waifu.
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm somehow doing worse.
I'm somehow doing worse.
That's deadly.
Oh, he's stomping me.
Guys, I forgot the strats.
I don't know.
I just...
I forgot how to play, I guess.
I guess I just somehow just forgot how to play.
Oh my god, I didn't need to.
I did not mean to slash.
I keep trying to slash, but I shouldn't slash.
But maybe I can slash right here, though.
But maybe what if I slash right here?
But what if...
Oh, and now it flies.
it's taking off I met her quarrel once, watch out Jesus
Christ I don't remember how this goes oh my God how oh oh my
god when it starts flying oh they don't when they start
flying I'm never prepared.
It's fine.
I'm downloading it.
I keep forgetting.
Oh, my shield.
Control.
I need to remember the control eye.
Jesus.
God damn it.
It's just so strong.
When he does that thing I think the worst part because I
can't dodge that like
That machine was created by a bunch of mad scientists Ooh
Boom Oh my god, it's actually taking damage damage.
It can.
That's possible.
Invasive action.
What's that?
My robot wife keeps telling me to dodge.
I don't know what that means.
Alright.
What if I just walk up to it?
I just take the whole thing.
Fuck it.
What?
Okay, that was bullshit.
That was bullshit.
That was a bullshit.
Alright, it's gonna fly now.
It's gonna fly now.
What the...
It's taking off.
Is this the...
There we go.
This could be some good R&D data back to the workshop.
Oh god.
There we go.
What?!
I'm so mad.
I'm trying!
It's just stunning me!
It's fine.
I was so close.
I wanted to be on top of him.
I want to fly higher.
I might have flown too close to the sun.
I was like, but what if I was higher than him?
That was you.
I was just like, but what if I was taller?
Guys, what if?
I just wanted to be taller.
Okay.
That machine was created by a bunch of bad scientists.
Jesus.
Oh my god, tank that entire fucking shot.
Holy shit, that was not a good idea.
Okay, this is not the run.
I might have just tanked it.
This is definitely not the run, guys.
What?
That hits me!
That's bullshit!
Fuck this.
Sash!
I know that will over...
overheat you.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
Slash!
Get overheated!
There we go.
Slash!
Get overheated again!
Okay, now it's up in the sky.
Okay.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh my god, I'm just kidding.
That was an accident.
That was actually an accident.
I didn't mean to take that.
Push back, Taurus.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
That was an accident!
I swear to God!
Smash it up, Taurus.
I'm trying!
He's so high!
Oh, I'm so fucked.
I'm actually so fucked right now.
At what point does it stop being an accident, Toki?
At what point?
Oh, no!
I'm dead.
No, we were so...
I just can't beat the institution.
It went right there.
We were right there.
It was just an accident.
Oh my god.
Guys, I should have started.
Guys, my oopsie is when I stopped buying new gear.
It's just like, all I need is big boom.
What new gear?
That might have been my hubris Where I was just let What do
you mean, new gear?
Alright
Alright Alright
Oh fuck that was oh my god What?
He comboed me so hard!
The price you pay.
Missed, but it was missing.
Oh my god!
He just fucking comboed me with his big boom!
Punished for being in the air.
Now if you could just step inside.
Okay.
Wait.
Enemy detected.
Alright.
Spy.
There we go.
One of the institutes relics left to haunt me with haunt.
Alright, there we go.
Oh shit, no!
Don't pickpoo me!
Come on!
Come at me!
Here we go.
Boom!
Okay.
Oh,
he's gonna land on me, isn't he?
all right
all right oh shit he boomed me though he's booming me oh
fuck there you go I
gotta put this on real quick oh my god is he in the air he
is in the air in you.
It's taking off.
Whoa!
Wow!
This could be some dead R&D, David.
Okay.
All right, I gotta stay back on the ground.
Whoa!
Okay.
All right.
I'm trying.
I'm trying!
Oh, God.
Oh god, oh god, oh god
Oh fuck There we go Oh, I've got stun too, that little bitch
Boom Okay, I locked in for real this time I was fucking
around too much I
guys sorry i was messing around a little too i felt like it
was time to actually lock in you know i was just fucking
with you guys i didn't know i was just pretending to be bad
i figured it was time to stop playing around you know i i
figured it was time to actually play the game for real
sherry she finally turned on the modder.
I know.
Never doubt it.
I was just like, you know, ah man, I think I've, I think I
trolled enough.
I think I milked the content enough.
Yeah.
I don't know.
You tell the difference between when I finally locked in.
Yeah, you like that bit I did?
Right.
Yeah.
I finally plugged in the keyboard.
You want to thank you for the super chat?
Thank you.
I have to add a bit of tension, you know?
It won't be funny if I first try every boss.
I guess a dog can't choose its master.
But still, tough luck.
I have to make sure, like, you know, I'm infallible.
I'm just like you guys.
I want to be more relatable, you know?
I have to, like, lose so I can be more relatable.
to you guys.
Good job, Doki.
That was for sure the hardest boss in the game.
Don't worry, it gets easier from here.
And then see, I feel like you're lying.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Do you think this guy is lying?
Oh, that's beautiful.
Raven?
You see it too, don't you?
See what?
Oh my god, the voices in my head.
Because if I take the meds, I won't hear her.
Oh, the coral.
It speaks to me.
What does the coral say?
That was the hardest boss in the game so far.
The easiest boss for the rest of it.
Airport.
Thank you.
Super chat.
The coral.
It's here in this desolate place.
Alright.
Oh my gosh.
My money.
That's a lot of money.
Nero, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Slow, slow.
Quick, quick, slow.
I don't think it was Super chat.
Thank you.
Not to condone your unlicensed use of mech, but have you
considered using your ability to run circles around the
spider, aka use your zoomies?
Thank you, thank you.
You see, we've been big booming for so long with our tank
build.
I forgot what it was like to have legs.
I forgot what it was like to use legs.
I'm so used to being a giant ass big boy.
looks like you've made it to the central ice field all right
we'll do chat build you guys help me customize my met
archivists found their own way in and are ready to deploy
survey squads and it looks like balem's come running after
you scoped out the place too you know what's going to happen
business as usual oh no but you can make it work for us
Registration number RB 23 call sign Raven your records have
been updated D rank virtual encounters are now available in
the arena.
Oh shit nice.
These correspond to the middle ranks You can fight more I
can fight more megas your technique All right before we do
this I need to go pee so you guys can go argue amongst
yourself on what the build can be like I'll be right back Oh
never mind my voice talking to me and I discovered thing you
might want to know about what is it darling it's a network
service that was labeled nest with no obvious clues about
its purpose from what i can tell it's a special mercenary
support program encrypted and kept secret oh i've installed
the back door so you'll have no trouble getting in as you
please all right i'll be right back guys my wife's done
talking i'll be right back gotta pee
Oh my god, I'm trying to mute.
Oh no, my GoXLR.
Why is GoXLR not letting me mute?
It's sick.
Oh, it's because my GoXLR was never on.
What the fuck?
Guys, was my mic okay throughout that?
Oh, no.
okay throughout that uh l meddy rice david uh bite thank you
the super chat oh it's been fine okay that's good all right
i'll be right back for real
i'm ready all right i was ready to do buy some parts all
right what do we buy we're not replacing the boom zone i'm
sorry guys big boom stays unless yes big boom stays it's
just we will do legs legs and oh new boosters okay what
boosters do we buy this one high mobility develop commission
songbirds and pal what the fuck is songbird oh is that the
cannon this one oh is that big boom oh my god is that bigger
boom wait is that bigger
all right there's such a thing as a bigger
no way okay it was this right yeah i have to buy do i have
songbirds on this side literally bought some oh wait i
didn't hear you all right we bought songbird
they're op oh i I like the sound of that.
Alright, what about legs, guys?
I have to buy two songbirds, but then the other one is a
missile.
Okay, boosters.
Alright, boosters, guys.
Which one?
Tell, talk to me in prices.
2-1-Z?
This one?
The 200?
I guess it's because it has the...
All right, we'll grab that because it's the most expensive.
Okay, fine.
We'll grab two of the songbirds.
Okay, I have enough for, I don't know.
All right, I don't have a lot now.
Whoa, wait, what is this?
Oh, my God, I can be a tall tank.
Is that Wait, I want to save up for this Wait a minute I
want to I want to save up for this guy Alright, alright
We'll save, wait, actually we can sell it Okay, I should
have enough money to sell stuff Alright, let's piece stuff
together Okay, where's my song bird
Here's what there's the other I run sword or big boom I
don't know maybe big boom okay which one are my other big
booms it was this run right bazooka which does more damage
oh this does more damage alright I was so bad with the
pallet bunker I just remember that's the sword right yeah I
was so bad was this it's okay i'll try it one time but i
just remember being absolutely terrible with the pal bunker
how you been holding up welcome to give us super chat thank
you thank you yeah that too yeah i mean it's true i was i
was on tank build all right
let's try this out try the arena okay next All right, a born
con artist.
What the fuck is that?
Spray.
No shame was too underhanded.
You stun and then charge?
Okay, it's too underhanded for Wu Huai Kai during his days
as a criminal mastermind and exploitation of others was a
byword for opportunity.
However, his illicit Feng Shui pharmacy operation was a
fatal off-floor step, economic sphere and leading to
widespread disease.
It was now.
Now the duty.
Oh, I am.
Oh, wait.
You're right.
Wait.
But what can I do?
Go.
What can I do?
I don't have anything.
Oh, wait.
I can make have smaller arms, I guess.
Alright.
Tine your arms.
There you go.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Even tine your arms.
A little tine your arms.
There we go.
my little tiny arm arena combat altitude evaluation program
number 22 alright oh I forgot the booster oh fuck okay it's
fine we know we will be okay what is that oh it's a is that
fish and a dragon I mean that's a hardcore spray from
chicken legs I forgot it's okay this is the arena it's just
all simulation okay which one is my sword and Which one's my
big boom?
Ooh, wait, this guy's fast.
Wait a minute.
Okay.
This guy's fucking fast.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Fuck this.
You're so...
fast, bro.
Holy shit.
Oh my, okay.
Alright, wait.
Why are you a chicken?
Wait, what does that mean?
It's because my legs are tiny.
Who do you mean?
Oh, charge it.
Okay.
This is my training with my new weapons.
I've been using Big Boom for so long.
I don't know how to do anything else.
Okay.
you don't understand i've i've been a big boom player for so
long i don't i've never done
wait what why didn't i hit that it's so weird
all right oh shit oh
You got to be really, really...
Oh, okay.
Okay, I get it.
I get it.
No tracking.
Okay, I thought I had, like, tracking shit or something.
Bum-bum.
Where did he go?
It's just, like...
Wait a minute.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
Get your fucking ass over here.
here that's oh my god whoops whoops oh my god he just runs
away like a bitch no he stuns me I did get you see as I say
I'm so bad with the I'm so bad with this one move this bit
fight back
yeah oh my god he fucking still gets me
and where did he go you fucking
i think my first attempt was my best attempt not gonna lie
I'm pretty sure Yeah, my first attempt was definitely my
best one
Jesus Then charge Use a sudden charge the bunker often used
But I got a time and like chat says Oh, okay Well, thank you
for the super chat Thank you, thank you Stun boosting, close
then power bunker
bitch i hate you your family dies oh my god he stuns me
that's it oh i fucked up i'm just gonna move i'm just gonna
stand next to you
fuck this there we go oh you're gonna stun me like a little
I just need more practice with I don't know this build I
don't know how to use this build at all main system
activating combat mode
oh my god he stuns me and I stun him back fuck
I'm locking He's just standing above me
Oh my god I'm too used to big boom
Big boom was like my crutch For so long
I don't know how to function without...
Big boom.
But...
I'm just like, how do I play without it?
Are you serious?
Get over here, I don't care.
I don't fucking care.
AP at 30%.
Oh my god
No No I got the stupid I'm at the stupid build I guys I
don't think this build is for me I Legitimately Guys I don't
think this build is for me Guys Third Guys this build might
not be for me Where did this fucker go oh my god
okay okay
give me no what how does he not
your thing was red your thing was red
guys we all saw it
we all saw it being red
That's actually bullshit.
You were red.
Check his tag.
Jesus Christ.
I
don't care.
I got your I got your legs.
I got your fucking legs
Oh my god, you serious
My god, I don't care.
I don't care get out of here.
Oh my god
Okay Yo, oh my god
I would never surrender
Yes.
Alright, maybe...
Okay.
What am I using?
Alright.
Do I have anything that's not a big...
Okay, maybe I'll shoot it.
I'll shoot it with a gun.
Oh my god, look at me.
Regulated to gun mode.
like a fucking peasant like a fucking peasant there we go
like a fucking peasant what the what oh we had the boosters
i didn't even realize I didn't realize I still forgot to put
on the booster.
Which one did I bought this?
Okay.
Alright.
Look what they did to me.
Having to use my gun.
Like a fucking peasant.
Oh my god.
Fuck this.
I don't care.
I know.
We're supposed to use it when they're red.
Oh my god.
Bring me back to the good.
Back to the good old days.
Hey, boy.
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
Back to the good old days.
Oh my
god, whoops.
Back to the good old days.
For if it meant something.
There we go.
Why do anything different?
If it works...
Oh my god, I couldn't even see where he is.
Why did I even try?
Why?
Why did I even try to do anything different?
I'm broken.
Why fix it?
Why did I even try?
What?
What was the point?
What did she...
If it ain't broke...
What was the point in doing anything different?
It was just... This just works.
You don't even get to be... You don't even get to be... You
have to...
help let's all agree to never be creative again
all right literally one shot after swapping back all right
everyone more impersonal attendant to doll mine freddy
maintains an aloof distance from his fellow comrades and
admire the inner world of doll marion's mind he entered the
battlefield oh wait ready in 10 yeah guys all right we're
gonna have like i'll be we're gonna have like an impromptu
street fighter session when duos doesn't work 10 token takes
it's like good thank you super chat thank you thank you all
right what's the point exactly what the fuck was the point
oh fuck yeah let's try the laser gun my arms are too small
to hold anything else all
right wait oh i don't i can't use boosters there's no point
all right
arena combat aptitude evaluation program number 21 rank d
all right here we go subject ac candle ring call sign ring
freddy ring freddy
main system activating combat mode oh it's my other good now
oh
my god is that the wheelchair that's the wheelchair right
holy shit he's so fast but i am sorry oh my god doesn't
matter where is he
no they keep running away from me!
The moment I get close!
I'm putting you... No!
It keeps... It keeps running away the moment I want to sort
him.
He's the little bitch boy!
Ooh, I have a little headache though.
And they got too passionate.
Could be the blood.
Activating combat mode.
Okay.
Yes!
Oh my god, I don't even know.
Oh my god, he's so fast!
What?
He's so fast!
Stop in the name of the law!
Oh my god, he's actually too fast for me.
There we go.
I got him.
Not fast enough.
I'll put you in a wheelchair, wheelchair.
That's a key, right?
Look how easy it is now.
There we go.
There we go, guys.
I don't know why I even tried to be creative there.
why try anything new just stick to what you know why did i
even try i can't i know i can have bigger arms maybe big arm
yeah big arm wait i don't even know about this these arms
are better are they better or would the first arm be better
i can't tell i feel like the first arm would be better right
Tien Lo.
Or the Mind Alpha.
Band show arms.
What the fuck is that?
The numbers.
What do they mean?
What do the numbers mean?
The D-F-A-R-O now.
First one is better.
Alright.
What about my big ass body oh this one i forgot this one is
definitely better there we go if it ain't broke if it ain't
broke why that's it we're going back to the big booms all
right this squad leader of the vespers the aqueous groups
augmented human squad like swineburn hawk is a member of the
generation and has lost a great many colleagues in
subordinates uh to the progress of science and
revolutionizing the surgery however he has reached a certain
peace with their sacrifices knowing that his generation of
surgery is far safer than those of the past free of the loss
of humanity inflicted on the coral technology generations or
the grizzly accents of the interim generations all right
all right here we go
broke, guys.
The moment I went back to my roots.
Don't know why I tried anything different.
Where is he?
Oh, I'm tanky, tanky.
Oh my god.
I am very tanky.
Oh my god, I sure am dinky now.
Oh, shit!
Oh, yeah?
My turn!
Oh, shit.
Wait, he did it back to me.
My god.
Here we go, it's five.
What the fuck did I hit him?
I couldn't tell.
Oh my god, I can't even fucking slap him.
Oh my god, wait, he's slapping me back.
Wait a minute, that's illegal.
Wait, he slapped me back!
Now he...
Wait a minute.
You mean he can parry me?
That's no, no.
That's just a fluke.
guys he was lucky he was lucky guys
maybe this would hit him imagine if that did hit him though
that would be pretty funny
right no i didn't hit it oh shit
how did i not hit oh my god that's illegal that's illegal Oh
guys, guys, I'm not hitting anything.
I, like, he's so fast or something.
Hey guys, why is he so fast?
Oh my god, he's getting above me.
He's dead, this is illegal!
Ref!
Oh my god, you bitch.
You bitch
No, he just no no wait wait no no no this is just a fluke
guys this is just a fluke
Guys This is just a fluke
Ha oh wait, I didn't even realize there's a range like he
got above me Yeah like that's bullshit oh my god what if
okay there you go fucker you fucker yeah
oh my god i try to slash you and he slashed me back fuck
this fuck you
Oh my god, you bitch!
You're so lucky this is so much an open-ended area!
You are so lucky!
You're so lucky!
There we go.
Get out of here!
I'll fucking clip your wings!
It's like he's in the air stun, so he's out of range.
It's okay.
It's alright, guys.
I made it.
Doesn't matter.
Wings won't save you.
Everyone will fall eventually.
Alright.
See, guys?
It's just that easy.
Look at that.
Gun 5 of the Red Guns.
The Baum Group's AC Squad.
A Backstreet Gambler.
Uh.
Lao-Gzu bet big and lost, and he was forced to undergo
experimental fourth-generation augmentation surgery to pay
back his debtors.
In his new life, he quickly began to quarrel with Volta.
In his oftentimes partner in crime, Iguazu, recall creature
nature was such that one day he even picked a fight with the
hero Jupiter, who retaliated with such fury that Iguazu
never quite looked the same afterwards.
What did he do?
Like, slapped him?
Showed everyone that he's a beta bitch?
I'm gonna show everyone again that's right arena combat
aptitude evaluation program number 19 ranked D
all right a gauzu call sign gun five Iguasu all right time
to show the world how much you are little bitch all right
where is he I have my big guns here ready to say hello.
No, you think you're fast enough for big guns?
You are.
Maybe you are.
But nobody's fast forever.
You cannot run me, little boy.
You cannot run me for forever oh my god maybe you can bro
that's a great that's right a little boy can't outrun me
he's nothing easiest fucking kill in my life
destroyed all right i guess one last arena a wondering
independent mercenary who shelters with the rubicon
liberation front well versed in law and law's classical
theater he has particular interest in ninjas and kabuki
relics of the past that he learned from of from the japanese
immigrant culture which now which now heavily influences is
eccentric style once when Roku Monson was on the brink of
starvation.
He was rescued by ZE.
Go after him food and shelter.
And ever since that day, he has been swarmed.
And any of those who would do higher and are caught.
Have I killed her yet?
I don't remember.
I've killed so many.
Oh, he's a weeb.
Have I killed ZE yet?
Might be a little troublesome.
Ha!
Baby child's clip.
Arena Combat Apptitude Evaluation Program.
Number 18.
Ranked D.
Yeah?
Oh, yeah.
Oh yeah, no wonder he hates me.
Subject AC, Shinobi, call sign, Roku Monsen.
Alright, little weeb.
It's time to send you back home.
It's time to deport you.
Main system, activating combat mode.
Whoa!
Damn.
He really wants to get close to me.
All right.
Hey, you're almost there.
Oh, shit.
Wait, he stunned me.
Wait a minute.
It's not fuck you.
I know I should have hit him.
Like, he was there, all right?
I took the shot.
I might as well.
He was literally...
Boom!
Oh, my God.
You're such a little bitch.
You are...
You are fine.
I'll be in shield, too.
That's why we'll both play like this.
We'll both be little bitches together.
Get out of here.
That's looking right.
Wow.
After 80 tries.
On whatever the fuck move out of those chicken legs.
I first try on tank.
Why does he go easy?
It's not easy.
It's called skill diff.
It's called Skill Death, guys.
G-G's.
Now get the wheelchair.
Congratulations.
You have surpassed rank D.
We hope that our aid has helped push you to achieve greater
things.
Think build best build, just in case you didn't know, some
weapons can be charged.
Oh yeah, yeah.
But sometimes I'm just impatient.
Machiso, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, let's try the wheelchair.
I should have enough of it now.
Bye.
Where is the wheelchair?
This one, right?
All right.
Oh, I need the...
Oh, I'm a little too heavy right now.
Oh.
Oh, I can't hold all of these things.
Oh,
it's still a little too heavy.
I guess I have to...
There we go.
I got...
I changed my chest.
Fuck it.
Alright.
Uh...
Alright, there we go.
Arms or chest?
I'm less thick now.
Yeah, I should have changed the arms instead.
I mean, I could.
I think this was the thick...
Yeah, and then arms.
Because I'll be here.
Oh, yeah.
That still works.
Alright.
What's next again?
Oh, this is where you guys can beat me up.
No, that's fine.
No, that's alright.
I think I'm good.
I...
Um...
Enhance all sorts.
I should get that, right?
What should I get?
Should I get the melee one?
I should, right?
I'm not a coward.
I just don't have enough gear.
Oh, the repair kit.
I guess I could.
Yeah.
I finished the repair kit.
Weight control?
Which one's that?
Oh, there it is.
So we went to the ability to manually purge.
Boy, I don't want to purge my weapon.
Direct hit damage is good.
This one?
Oh yeah, I should get that.
I'll grab that.
What is swordy overburden?
What does swordy overburden mean?
Man, try.
Um...
Do I need to, like, assemble that?
No, right?
Like, I have that automatically equipped, right?
Assume so.
Oh!
Oh, I can go when I'm over- Oh!
Okay.
Wait, I don't know if I should- Alright, I'm just waiting
until- Okay, whatever, I'm just doing a mission.
I don't know if I need to practice Street Fighter now.
Aquarius survey captain sees the corporation's observation
data extra rewards based on numbers all right of enemies
destroyed all right let's go oh i could equip my old arms
i'll do that later when i'm in six two one it's a request
from one of the balum companies attention gun 13 raven this
job comes from our subsidiary da fuck
central ice fields y'all are mine i want you to stage an
attack on the archivist survey camp located there i got my
wheelchair guys it was pretty expensive my insurance went up
whatever they found is sure to contain clues as to the
whereabouts of the coral convergence put simply your job is
to seize the data we're counting on you gun 13.
That's me.
I believe in me.
All right.
Let's grab my big ass arms in here.
That's five.
Mobility impaired.
What mobility will I mean?
I'm still hearing things.
What mobility?
I bet I won't even notice.
I won't even notice it.
That's good.
Make them come to me.
Hey, how bad could it be anyway?
Oh, it's not that bad.
It just feels like me on my regular tank.
Oh, wee.
Oops.
I'll go over it this way.
I do not notice.
In fact, this feels faster than my other build.
Oh shit, whoops.
All right.
I'm just gonna stab him just for fun.
Where are they?
Oh, there it is.
Whoops.
oh wait i'm sorry i i'm so used to just shooting everything
uh no major change in value compared readings recorded in
the valius region likely to be senders from the fires of
ebis and their core readings make up 80 in total analysis
underway of the remaining 20 percent all right
faster recharge though that shit is slow 800 okay it's over
here
it's nice that oh nice did not realize they would die that
fast not gonna lie whoops a little embarrassing for them is
that it wow pretty shitty ass defense here oh Fuck, I'm
sorry!
Alright.
This can cover me.
Most of these installations appear to have been built by the
Planetary Closure Administration.
After the
fires of Evis, they must have been made redundant by the
subsequent completion of the closure system.
That's a bit of elbow grease.
We might be able to repurpose these old ruins.
Okay.
Oh my that's it you know I was gonna let you live that's it
never again oh shit wait you're an actual guy there you go
cute is he gonna is he alive oh my god he's alive wait he's
actually alive what the Fuck, wait, I don't want to deal
with this.
Oh, shit!
Yeah!
Okay.
Alright, I guess I do have to deal with this.
Oh, my God.
You're such a little whore.
You're actually such a little whore.
Where's the other guy?
Where did he go?
Whoops.
Oh my god, there you are.
Okay.
Okay, that's awkward.
There we go.
Yeah, get out of here.
Get your ass out of here.
And this is overkill.
Alright.
I need to figure out how to get back up here.
Who poked me?
Who was it?
Are you there?
There we are.
Let me figure out how to get back up.
Oh, there it is.
Wee!
Alright.
Alright, now we can go back up.
Two repair kits remaining.
I might have used up all my money.
But it's about sending a message.
All right.
I don't need the money.
These guys are so indifferent about you.
How about you breaking?
Oh, that's just Jokey B, the independent YouTuber in a
building-sized metal demon.
He was Super Chat Airborne.
Thank you.
50%.
All right.
I have to go up.
Jokey, we need more.
money for ammo so so you can do more big boom more money
equals more boom i don't understand oh wait it's over here
all right there you go
analyze uh
our video data of the ocean region has noticeable gaps
strangers still this whole not record remains regardless of
how many drones we send what's going on here some kind of
camera interference money can be exchanged for goods and
services what are you doing here looks like their mts just
got home shut them down is it that guy oh more things that
boom oh it's free real estate free real estate hours right
here oh wait that's not that's not just a regular guy you
know what
free real estate boom that's fucking right get out of here
welcome to the slaughterhouse oh oh wait there's still one
more where's the last one oh my god it's there all right big
damage tab all right keep going
oh shit maybe I need to make sure I don't fall into the
depths just no maybe I can reach that whoa whoa let's hope I
please touch this please okay
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Gotta figure out how to get there.
Give me a sec.
There must be a way to reach this.
In my turn, no way, I'm too heavy.
Wait, I have an idea.
I have a plan.
Okay, I'm planning, guys.
What the fuck?
Where this guy comes from?
Alright, watch this.
Okay, we're gonna do that.
And then...
There we go.
We hover.
Eee!
Easy!
So easy!
Sonar is picking up something strange, whatever it is, you
can't miss it.
Some kind of massive cave perhaps?
How could you be a cavity underneath this vast sheet of ice?
It's like flappy bird, exactly.
Flappy mech.
That's me.
Looks like you ruffled some feathers.
Taking their drones back to HQ.
I want you to find them and stop them.
Oh, wait, there's more?
This guy?
Whoops.
Eventually it worked.
Guys, I have a feeling that I might be running out of money.
How do I get over there?
there wait
a minute this is a little awkward hope i make it yay i made
it let's go all right
where is it oh it's over there how do i get over there is it
like up here
dassey thank you for this super Thank you, thank you.
Um, I might have spent the entire military budget on booms.
Uh, whoops.
I might have just spent our yearly budget on one mission.
Can you really blame me, though?
Guys, is it really my fault?
Oh, shit!
Can you really blame me?
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck?
Okay.
I'm here.
Oh, nice.
Resupply.
Look at that.
It's like I didn't waste the entire yearly budget.
Look at that, guys.
Oh, fuck.
Oh my god, what happened to me?
Oh my god, he's running away.
It's like a giant time missile in the face or something.
It's like that's a bad idea.
Who would have known?
He also had big boom.
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
Am I supposed to shoot that?
That's not subject guard.
Did they send in an enforcement squad?
Raven, fight back.
The fight back.
I'm trying.
Oh, wait.
The PCA's rank and file.
Did a big step up from subject guard and tease.
What am I getting shot at?
I'm getting shot by 20 different things.
Ah, don't be careful, but what?
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
I'm just gonna do this just in case.
There we go.
We destroyed him.
And just everything in here.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
What do I do?
Can I just shoot it?
Oh, no.
I fucked up.
Yeah!
I fucked up a little bit, guys.
Just a little bit.
I'm on the bridge.
About that.
But, um, I might have missed the bridge by just one
centimeter.
I might have I might have just missed it by like just one
centimeter I mean it's just a little bit of a little oopsie
daisy he he you know whoopsie daisy little mistakes you know
Doesn't everybody?
Holy fuck.
I'm just gonna let them shoot that It's identifying as PCA
Alright I'm just hoping he doesn't shoot me Wow
Whoa, hey stop cheating
Oh my god, I'm getting like fucking double teamed right here
by 800 mechs
There you go get this guy out of here fucking sniper playing
like a goddamn pussy Where are you?
I need to get this pussy out of here.
Boom There we go All right, where's my actual fighter?
There you are.
Who's the guy that actually has to fight?
Oh my gosh, wait.
Who is the other guy that actually has to fight?
Oh, there you are.
Are you the guy that's supposed to actually fight?
Yeah, you are.
Oh, that's awkward.
That's... whoops, that's awkward.
There we go.
all right we gotta go to the worship again oh my giant ass
team okay no no all right
yeah i'll make it this time i'll make it this time i'm gonna
make it i made it i told you guys
There's a lot of stuff on my screen.
It's going to blow.
Get clear, 6-2-1.
Oh my god.
Am I alive?
I made it just in time.
Worship down.
I repeat.
There you go.
I did it.
The easiest fight of my life.
So easy.
Cool guys, don't look at explosion.
I'm pretty sure that ship was insured anyway.
It'll be fine.
Special mission maybe.
Or was it?
Wait.
We're there.
What?
Is
it for me?
Who could have done such a thing?
The space government.
Oh, no!
I wonder who they're trying to go for.
See, look at that camouflage.
Guys, look at that.
Hiding in plain sight.
Yeah, who called the fence?
I told you.
I told you this is perfect camo.
Couldn't even see me.
I wonder who that message is for.
Wow.
Guys, I need some help with budgeting.
I don't know what to do.
For some reason, they keep taking my money.
And I don't know how to stop that.
Gringo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't know what to do.
I don't know what to cut in my budget.
Hmm, I guess I gotta stop taking damage or something?
Uh, what can I do to save more money?
I guess I'll never know.
Stop using...
Are you crazy?
Useless?
Boom.
You might as well ask me to die.
Airport Ninja, are you a super chat?
Thank you.
I'd love to catch up, but I'll cut to the end.
chase the pca has deployed its suppression fleet and now
it's laying down the law all over robicon stop using
explosives on everything no you're right i should just
increase taxes just stop being taxed liberation front sees
this as an opportunity okay oh the feds once what did i do
wrong i'm just doing my job god people can't make a living
anymore in this society i'm sending you a request from the
archivist group we could use the wall climbers help oh malo
you're gonna super chat thank you thank you will they even
super chat thank you thank you here's your yearly budget
increase you know how like usually when the government or
like when a company or investors give you a budget you have
to spend it all um or they'll like they'll be like oh we
gave you too much money so we have to decrease your budget
so like like the military or like the government they buy
like useless things because they want to keep their
consistent budget or have a higher budget even if it's like
worthless items both sides have been forced to halt the
coral survey check the briefing 621 yeah you use it or you
lose it because if you don't use up the budget like the
money just doesn't go anywhere you too so now they got they
have to increase my budget now
all right oh
wait there's a lot more missions now let me as uh down for
one every
i think i don't think my coach was like oh she's streaming
an armored core.
I don't think she's ready.
I've been ready whenever.
Alright, what do I want to do?
Attacked of your fueling base seized by the planetary
closure administration destroyed the energy plant women.
He was like, will you be ready in 10 minutes?
And I was like, yeah.
And that was like that might have been like 30 minutes ago.
So I just wanted to be sure.
Yeah.
Um, you know what?
I fight.
We've received a job from the Rubicon Liberation.
Oh, it's for Street Fighter.
Let's take a look at the request.
We have a mission we'd like to offer you.
Rubicon Liberation Front is planning to retake the wall.
We're armoring my core.
That's fucking right.
I'd like you to lay the groundwork for us.
Your objective is to assassinate V7 Swinburne.
Oh, it's him!
We fought this guy before in the training room.
That's the...
What's that word called?
The brain pig, dad.
The lobotomy man, yeah.
It's the lobotomy man.
I'm ready.
ambush and eliminate the target undetected we all need to
adopt a different style of fighting a different style of a
fighting adapting they have to adapt to me oh wait what it's
a stealth mission wait oh oh wait a minute
Wait a minute.
Commence mission.
I've estimated the target's position based on the data we
received.
Sending results now.
Watch out for the surveillance empties.
If they get a read on you, this operation is over.
If you pick up a capture camera tracking you, take cover or
quickly destroy it.
okay i just hugged this can i just destroy this what happens
if i just go okay nobody knows wait what if i just wait
watch this guys he's gonna stand still watch this
oh did not expect that to work all right there you go no
witnesses
you think they know
wait the moment he stands still
I mean they're in giant mechas of course they won't hear
there we go guess who's gaming tonight there's a lot of
surveillance entities Raven check to see where they're
employed you mean all right oh shit wait that's a lot of
them oh no wait I could watch this guys
there we go easy and you guys said big boom is bad oh
and you guys doubt the big boom just hugged the wall
honestly it's been working so far wait wait let me
oh oh
here here we go
If it works, it works.
It must have been the win.
Let's hide in the trees.
Ha!
Made it!
Last night of the target, it seems.
Perhaps he's on a night watch.
oh it's over there oh stealth baby that's what's over there
oh it's over there i was gonna say how the i'm gonna fly up
there these lawless ruffians it's stealth but there's no
witnesses always remember that this isn't how the liberation
front builds their acs Target confirmed.
It's Swinburne.
The Vesper is number seven.
This is an opportunity for an ambush.
Let's go.
All right.
I see.
Baila.
Tired old concern falling further and further behind.
I'll have you all sent for re-education.
Whoa.
I'll be pleased to have you.
Wait, could I...
Is that him?
Oh, he's so strong.
Ambush!
What do you think you're playing at?
That's right!
Ah, yes!
Boom!
Oh, wait, wait.
Well, that's awkward.
That's awkward for me.
Wait, he's killed.
Wait a minute.
What's that?
how are you healing?
Yeah?
which means I hold the purse strings.
Every single transaction goes through me.
Confirmed?
No, please?
Yeah?
Confirmed.
Target destroyed.
Woo-yo!
Let's go home.
No mercy.
No fucking mercy.
No deal.
We don't negotiate.
With Corpus.
You could have spared him.
What do you mean?
You want this weak-ass bot?
in my team she missed the critical info and yeah he's go
wait he was gonna pay me okay all right maybe i should have
not shot first and explained later make the money you you
have you do have a chance to spare him new message whoops
raven you have our gratitude for eliminating swimburn Some
of us were worried that the enemy might have won you over
But it seems we can trust you after all Glad to be on the
same side But how we don't negotiate Wait, wait a minute,
look Wait, when money is on the line here I thought you
wanted to join my team And I was like, I'm not letting you
on my team Look at you, I beat the shit out of you Like But
when money was Yeah, we don't negotiate Unless you pay me
Yeah Halo thank you for super chat thank you thank you so
the fun thing about that boss you can actually take his
bribe you stop shooting and the RLL pilot fights you instead
or you take the bribe and while he's still talking and any
attack is one shot oh I could have got free I couldn't help
it I was like he's just standing there I might as well
finish the job I look if he was gonna bribe me me that in
the beginning before my sword was in his throne like lord
kurosus thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
yeah it's his fault he didn't lead with the bribe like lord
kurosus thank you with super chat thank you thank you no
gives happy corn sponsors i guess no need for
tried a little harder.
You should have brought me faster.
I don't think that was my fault.
He was gonna buy your merch.
I replayed.
He was, he talked to us.
Yeah, exactly.
He talked too slow.
Is it truly my fault?
all right let's tack this one hey buddy this job comes from
Schneider of the Archibus Schneider damn Schneider they want
you to attack the Yorgon refueling base a PCA foothold on
Rubicon the target is the energy refinery plant deep inside
take that out and well it ought to slow down their
suppression fleet at least until recently Jorgon was one of
Balaam's coral survey bases it only took a day for the PCA
suppression fleet to commandeer the base you'll also find a
number of fuel storage tanks that I've marked as pay targets
I want you to be a walking advertisement for opportunities
in destruction
All right.
Attack the refueling base seized by planetary closure
administration and destroy the energy plant within.
Okay.
That seems fine.
Um...
Coach said he's not ready yet.
Just focus on getting the job done.
Don't worry, I always get the job.
See?
I always get the job done.
Sometimes I get the job done too well.
system activating combat mode commence mission take out the
pca forces and head for the energy refinery plant by
destroying everything what counts as everything like enemies
or items suspected corporate hire single ac terminate
immediately Is it enemies?
But what counts as everything?
Items too?
How do I know if I destroyed an item?
How do I know what's indestructible and what's destructible?
I think that's a better question.
Sometimes I don't know.
Whoops.
Oh, dead of you little bitch get over here I'm gonna fucking
stab you that's right I think you can run oh look at them
hanging out oh that's a real guy I ain't scared get over
here oh my god wait never mind never mind but where did you
go stop stop flying above me that's illegal
oh my god you fuck it
there we go that's right get your ass out of here alright do
you think this is destroyable there we go just try and
figure out what I I can destroy and what I can destroy.
Oh, there it is.
Look at that hits.
Oops.
Oh, that did not hit.
I was like, wonder.
I mean, it'd be pretty cool if it hit.
Oh, no.
maybe I shouldn't just tank that whatever there you go whoa
I was gonna say you're still alive repair kit remaining can
I shoot this oh yes I can
code one five boom wait who shot me oh shit you guys did
It's all right, don't worry.
Don't worry.
Back to destroying things.
Wham!
All right, don't worry.
Give me a sec.
I'm overheated right now.
He's recharging.
All right.
There's more money down below the bridge.
Hmm.
If I get more money or...
They're so far.
I do like money.
But then, like, it's gotta be, like, convenient.
It's gotta be, like, on the way, you know?
Like, but, like, it has to be on the way, guys.
Like, that's different.
All right,
we're here.
Oh.
Okay, we got the read supply.
All right.
That's the refinery plant.
Two and six two one.
I'm shooting here right now.
Wait, that's destroyable.
What the fuck?
I can't even see what's hitting me.
Is it this?
What is this?
What are you, little guy?
Get this out of here.
I go this way now.
Hoop!
Alright, nice.
We're here.
boom I think I destroyed it it's a one-shot oh that's right
this oh oh shit it's the popo it's the cops scatter wait
that's two of them That's illegal.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, scatter!
The police are here!
Okay, this is not fair!
Oh my god, okay, let me use this first.
Oh my god, this is a secret.
so hard actually oh my god what's going on
okay oh i fucked that up
the fence
oh man
you're jumping me
oh my god how dare they i've identified pca sp special
forces special forces they're so fast whoa like this is not
fair this is a 2v1
whoa okay i mean i'll take this
Trying to.
I swear to God, I am trying to focus.
One at a time.
It's a little hard.
Guys, what is going?
Okay.
There we go.
We got one.
All right.
Oh my gosh, Dad!
There we go.
Cat dodged this, though.
That's fucking right.
You trying to gank me?
I ain't going back to jail.
Not again.
That's fucking right.
I told you.
I'm like, AI, I learned.
AI learning.
Oh, that.
Cat dodged this.
to inspire other mercenaries to work for Agabus.
Officer down.
It's that easy.
Can't arrest me if you're dead.
Alright, I'm getting the hang of the pile driver.
Guys, I'm sorry to get a hang of it.
One new message.
If I haven't been doing your taxes properly, chat that you
did how's what paid for the big boom impressive work on the
refueling base assault v4 has left me a message addressed to
you if i may i knew you could do it i knew i could i know me
too that is all we at the archivist group expect much from
you
Yay!
I am a gamer.
I wonder if I even need more better parts or not.
Nah.
I feel like my build is pretty good right now.
Alright, tunnel storage.
Destroyed with the active device within the underground
tunnel.
Extra rewards based on the number of enemies destroyed.
Alright.
Another one?
So fast.
Attention, Gun 13 Raven.
This request comes from our affiliate, Daphung.
We will be conducting a diversionary operation to attract
the PCA's attention.
You are to report to the Angerbred Tunnel in the Central Ice
Field.
It's a derelict watchpoint, slated for restoration by the
PCA in the near field.
Okay,
not too bad.
The objective is to distract the PCA and divert forces from
their local base.
I'm a good distraction.
Briefing over.
I have so many poems.
Don't worry.
Distraction's my middle name.
I don't think Dauphin appreciates your true value.
Big boom is sort of like distracting if you think about it.
It goes boom.
And then people go, where boom come from?
Activating combat mode.
Commence mission.
Destroy the old sensor at the end of the underground tunnel.
This place may be derelict, but it won't be left undefended.
Keep your guard up.
All right.
So we might have to go down.
Code one five, unaffiliated AC.
Attack white.
Why attack?
Money.
I mean like money.
I gotta make sure I don't fucking fall.
That's like my scariest part.
Damn right, I do.
Boom!
Oh, little baby.
Oh, wait.
Little baby lives.
Alright.
Alright, what about the other?
No!
Oh, my God.
I'm alive.
That was close.
That was a little too close, guys.
What the fuck?
Get these little babies out of here.
This is a real Mecca's job.
All right.
That's the target.
That is?
Protected by a basic shield just hit it from the inside It's
from the inside.
Oh There we go Easy wait, that's it.
I knew it was never that it Whoa, shit Ow, oh Shit Oh Oh,
shit Oh, I'm so heavy Sir!
Oh fuck!
Oh shit.
Oh, get out of here.
Ah!
How are they okay?
And me not!
Who's that trip?
Poor your status.
We can answer that later.
Get out now.
Oh my god, I'm trying.
Oh, shit.
At least I'm gonna reach it.
Oh, I reach it.
Okay.
We're almost out, guys.
That's okay, I'm still healthy.
Oh, God.
I'm trying.
How are these guys?
Okay.
Oh my god.
You're so healthy.
See guys?
I knew I'd be so healthy.
Look at that.
The only people that died were the evil ones who had no
families.
Yeah!
Look at that.
So easy.
you always put your life online it's okay the people who
died are the ones with no family and they're the evil ones
remember I'm the good guy all right oh my god I'm actually
making money now who would have thought I'm actually gaining
money oh wait it's her wait she beat me up still performing
well she's the one that beat me up the voices have gone away
at any rate whatever the voices are doesn't seem to be doing
any harm for now i was asking about you walter wait was this
a paycheck i can actually earn money turns out our friends
fears were warranted don't spend too long dealing with the
pca walter clock's ticking
Oh?
Two new messages.
Attention, call 13 Raven!
I have a message for you from Commander Michigan.
Following your success at the Anger Bread Tunnel.
Sounds like you stared death in the face when all that coral
came rushing up.
That's one way to light a fire under your ass.
Keep it alive for the next field trip.
Let's run out.
Registration number RB23.
Call sign, Raven.
Your records have been updated.
C-Rank virtual encounters are now available in the arena.
We invite you to further hone your technique.
Alright.
Yay!
Time to beat up more people.
Let's go.
Like, Kurosus, they give us Super Chat.
Thank you.
Nobody told Doki she can even play the mission to bully the
test pilot rookie and get paid to do.
You see, I thought about it, but then it requires me to
resell that part.
And I don't really want to do that.
That's the thing.
I thought about it, but I was just like, I don't want to
resell that.
Just want to, I just want to go boom.
Gun 4 of the red guns, the Balaam's group.
C squad.
After...
Uh...
Oh, wait.
Rookie pilot is not the stuff.
Oh, you mean the very first one?
Like, this one?
Wait, no.
Who was it?
This tester.
Oh, this one!
But I could get paid more?
One that could have been gun 13.
Um, Pencil tip.
Thank you.
It was super chat.
Hey, Jogi.
Today is my birthday.
Can you sing me?
Happy birthday.
Of course I can.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Pencil.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Oh my god.
I get paid $95,000 to just kill one noob?
Say less.
This is the bounty hunter board now.
It's like that bounty hunter website.
Alright, where is that little shit?
We're gonna teach him the real world.
He's gonna learn today.
He's gonna learn.
I'm coming for you.
Hey there, little guy.
Oh, who's we?
You mean you're...
Oh, you're still alive?
Oh, you're so lucky that...
You're so lucky.
Oh, you know what?
Oh, that's cute.
That is so cute.
My...
Look at that!
I gave him a look at that!
See?
I gave him a chance to do a little stab.
Hello.
I know.
That's it for this job, 621.
Return to base.
Just to send a message.
Yay, money!
Yay!
That's not him.
He's the one to sign up for the army.
It's like a little money I know.
I shot at him and then money came out of this mecca.
Isn't that great?
My little money peonata.
After beating a rebellious Volta and Igwaza Guizu into
submission, Michigan made it to his personal crusade to make
something of the two.
Thus began their daily hell.
For past seven years, neither Volta nor Igwaza have achieved
their goal to punch the living daylight of Michigan.
hell out of the red guns.
Alter has since admitted defeat and is now learning about
the business from Wu Hua Hi.
Alright.
We'll do this one.
I do like one or two more rears and I'll call it here.
I think I made a lot of progress.
My fuck is my color scheme?
It's called Camo!
Oh my god, it's tank versus tank.
Oh my god, his thing is a tank beetle.
Wait, that's That's hardcore.
Tank versus tank.
I'm camouflaged.
No one can see me.
Look I blend right in.
That's what camo's for.
Also, where the fuck is this guy?
Oh my god, is he also camo?
There we go.
Big boom!
Oh my god, we're both wheeled.
Wait, no.
His is also a tank.
Oh my god, we're just doing drive-bys.
But did I hit him?
I can't even tell.
We're both so fucking thinking.
Oh my god, you bitch!
You just dodged that!
Where did he go?
Okay, there we go.
I think I hit him.
I can't tell.
He keeps dodging.
like a heart there we go that I know I hit I know I hit that
you know what fuck this that's right shield mode bitch the
world of tanks I'm a better tank
360 there we go now that Was a hit.
That's right.
I'm a bigger tank.
That's fucking right.
Alright, we'll do one more arena.
Yeah, I had the build, guys.
Oh, I didn't even read his lore.
It's alright.
It's not that important to me.
That's how little you matter to me.
Your lore does not matter to me.
That's fucking right.
Oh my god.
The twins.
Is it like mad by two people?
What the lore?
Yeah, no need to read lore if they're just gonna die anyway.
Exactly.
He looks fast.
Don't worry.
Oh wait.
Oh my god.
It's...
Oh my God is is is is these is this guy it's fucking oh my
god it's oh my god it's not again not again not again
not you know I might have to call it here maybe Not again.
Not this bullshit again.
Never mind.
No, just get me out of here, honestly.
Just kill me.
Just fucking kill me.
Just...
Okay, okay, now...
Okay, I've downloaded.
I've downloaded his thing.
I've downloaded it.
I realized, like, when he started...
when we were like started blowing those bubbles i was like
hmm
maybe i'll hit who knows i don't even know how i did this
last time
how did i how did i do this last time
truly truly an anomaly
oh my god you know what let's you know what maybe future
this is a future jokies problem maybe maybe just maybe where
did he go where did where did he go yeah i'm gonna call it
here will it will it future jokie i love this smack mecha
fight this is future dokey's problem uh present dokey's got
a practice street fight i'm gonna do it off stream because
i'm a little tired now and i need to process stuff
anyway guys i hope you guys had a great time watching it's
always fun playing armored core i think next armor car
stream i'll make it a little okay next week is gonna be a
little Next week is going to be mostly Street Fighter.
And I'll do a watch a little off stream.
I'm going to do a little watch off stream because we have
like at least two coaching sessions next week and then the
tournament.
So next week is just Street Fighter until after the
So anyway, I'm not going to stream the coaching session
today.
I'll stream it next week.
Anyway, guys.
Oh, you guys had a great time watching.
Thank you guys for putting up with me pushing the streams
for 80 minutes because I was so fucking tired.
But I'm okay now.
I got my second win.
I'm going to try and stay up a little bit, too, so I can fix
my jet lag, TM, maybe.
Attempt to fix my jet lag.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture
check, get up, and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you set up for me, head to bed, because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Also, I don't know why I try to be creative there.
trying to do anything outside of tank build i know what i am
tank build and also big boom i know what i am all right bye
everybody bye